PAUL LEWIS: If you were born
at any other point in history,
you'd be completely stuffed.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm
full of [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL LEWIS: What
would you have done
if programming wasn't a thing?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Die in a ditch.
I would.
I really would.
PAUL LEWIS: It's a really
happy tale, isn't it?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I want to talk
about Pointer events.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
So the CSS thing where you
say, Pointer events none.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
No, the other one.
Because the other spec
that they made before,
we're going to write a new spec.
I know, let's name
exactly the same
as an existing CSS properties.
PAUL LEWIS: Yay.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No.
I'm talking about
the events one.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh.
Those, those are
brilliant, right?
Detailed spec, unifies touch,
mouse pointers, and gives you
all the everything
that you ever need
to just bring it all together.
Brilliant.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's great.
We're not doing it.
PAUL LEWIS: What?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We
do have good reasons.
It's a really detailed spec.
It says the order of all,
how everything should happen.
But there are
performance issues.
It's very similar
to mouse events.
You know when you move a
mouse across the screen
and you get the mouse move
events and the target changes
after every element.
PAUL LEWIS: Yup.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Pointer
events works in the same way.
And that means that as
you're doing a touch action,
it's going to have to do this
hit test throughout the touch.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Big
performance problem.
You could actually--
to be fair to them,
you can set a capture on it.
But then you've still got
the enter and leave events
on the element that
you've captured.
That's a big performance no-no.
And the unification stuff
that you mentioned--
PAUL LEWIS: Yay.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's not
as good as you think.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I
don't know about you,
but whenever I use touch
events, which we already have,
I usually use it because
I want something special
to happen with touch.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Like a
swipe action, or something
that I wouldn't want
to do with the mouse.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And that's
what I find most of the time,
that there are occasions, maybe
like a drag and drop action,
where you'd want touch and
mouse doing the same thing.
But mostly, not that.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
And there are also
features that it stops as well.
So pointer events, what
seems like another plus point
for them, is it's either
the user agent, the browser,
dealing with the
touch stuff or you.
No in between.
So if it starts scrolling,
you're out of the picture.
But we have features
that need that.
For instance, you're scrolling.
You scroll to the top.
And then you drag down.
PAUL LEWIS: Pull to refresh?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Pull to refresh.
So that's you letting the
user agent do part of it.
And then you want to
take over at that point.
You can't do that
with pointer events.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh.
That's horrible.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Right.
And it's just all of
these little things
that have got in the way.
But the main one is, we
already have touch events
in all the major
browsers except IE.
And pointer events
are not good enough
to justify kind of
throwing that out,
because we would have to support
for ages for all the sites
anyway.
And the good news as well
is Internet Explorer,
they recognize that
touch is not going away
and they are going to
implement it as well.
PAUL LEWIS: Hooray.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I wanted to get
something else off my chest.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, no.
Not again.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I know.
I know.
And I want to talk
about getting undressed
because it's not something
I'm very good at.
It's not something
I'm very graceful at.
But we bonded over
something about this.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes, we did.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And I wanted
it to go over it again,
because the final
moment of undress, which
is when I've gone through the
clumsy uncool underwear down,
and then what happens.
PAUL LEWIS: You absolutely have
to do a flick with your foot,
whoop, catch, and then slam
dunk into the wash basket.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And
then all of a sudden,
all of the clumsiness--
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, it's
gone because you're
naked and cool at that point.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
You're the coolest naked
person in the room.
Right.
But I was at home doing clumsy
undress and then the recovery,
whoosh, boom.
And I thought of you.
Paul.
Naked Paul.
How am I expected
to live my life?
PAUL LEWIS: Now, we get an
API, the web smoothness API.